[Música]
yo hoy le había puesto el 11 de
septiembre cuando se cumplen 20 años de
los atentados contra las torres gemelas
en nueva york como la fecha límite para
retirar su uso 2.500 hombres de
afganistán pero adelantó la fecha las
tropas estarán de regreso antes del 31
de agosto sin embargo cerca de 1000
soldados estadounidenses seguirán en
terreno afgano para la protección de las
operaciones diplomáticas y el aeropuerto
de kabul en terreno seguirán ex
militares y consultores de seguridad
contratados por compañías militares
privadas que durante años ha contratado
el pentágono y que tratarán de hacerle
contrapeso al creciente poder de los
talibanes que según ellos ya controlan
el 85 por ciento del territorio afgano
de hecho ex oficiales del pentágono
advierten que el gobierno afgano no
logrará aguantar mucho tiempo tras la
retirada de las tropas estadounidenses
[Música]
afganistán era probablemente el único
país cercano a china en el que pekín no
le incomodaban las tropas
estadounidenses porque aportaban
estabilidad de hecho china en los
últimos años se ha convertido en el
mayor inversor en afganistán y había
firmado importantes contratos de
suministro de cobre y petróleo ahora
teme por ellos y teme también que les
sea más fácil operar en el terreno
aletín una organización terrorista o
yogur que en los últimos años había
cometido atentados en xinjiang y en el
resto del país a pesar de las promesas
del nuevo gobierno talibán de que
proteger a las inversiones chinas y de
que no permitirá que afganistán se
convierta en la base de operaciones del
equipo
la preocupación en pekín es más que
evidente tanto el gobierno como la
embajada en kabul habían criticado
fuertemente la marcha de las tropas
estadounidenses y hacía meses que
recomendaban a los nacionales que
abandonaran cuanto antes
afganistán
[Música]
rusia es mediadora en el conflicto
afgano y acogido incluso reuniones de
los talibán para facilitar el proceso de
paz a moscú le preocupa la estabilidad
en la zona porque tiene intereses en la
ssa central y sobre todo porque tres de
las naciones de esa región kazajistán
kirguistán y tayikistán son miembros de
la organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva una especie de alianza que
igual que la otan supone un pacto de
defensa mutua
el gobierno ruso teme la concentración
de efectivos del estado islámico en el
norte de afganistán por un lado lamenta
la apresurada retirada de la otan pero
por el otro tampoco quiere que la
retirada de eeuu se convierta en un
nuevo despliegue de fuerzas
estadounidenses en asia central para
garantizarles la seguridad músculo que
prefieres que se acabe la guerra entre
kabul y los talibán para que se unan
creando un gobierno de coalición para
que puedan enfocar sus esfuerzos en
derrotar al estado islámico en lugar de
luchar entre sí como llevan haciendo ya
desde hacerlo